foreign
let's go to Iowa City Iowa where Bo is
on the line Bo how can we help
hi thank you guys for taking my call
sure
all right so I'll get straight to it my
room so I have a renter I'm a roommate
and
um he's moving out and I don't know what
to do with my house based on my current
income
okay give us the numbers
all right so I make around 40 000 1925
hourly I'm an I.T guy for a company
around here
um and my mortgage is 13.50 Ish a month
a little bit more than that he pays me
500 in rent and then half a utility
which ends up being about 700 a month so
he told them they had a pretty big
amount right
um and uh well he's going to be moving
out so I'm gonna be taking over the
whole thing and I'm I do a budget each
month
um and as right now it's just looking
great you know but then I do a budget
for after he leaves and I see that after
all my expenses I only have 400 left
over yeah why don't you just get another
roommate yeah that's what I'm wondering
so I could like
um
he's a high school friend right
um and I'm not really like my high
school friends are incredible and I
would live with none of them
but Bo's the opposite John he's like I
only living with this guy because I like
him is that what I'm hearing
right yeah so like I'm not really sure
who else I'd have move in with me who
I'm like close enough because it's
Craigslist dude you'll get a list you'll
get some incredible applicants don't do
that don't do that
gotcha and so like I know I have a few
options I've been thinking over for a
few months now looking at Advance I one
of my best friends who does not want to
move and I asked him that actually
um but he wants to buy the house from me
for about fifteen thousand dollars more
than I paid for it
um and I bought this house less than a
year ago right
um and so like I think that's an option
but like and I have like I've been told
that I'm only 21 years old right I've
been told by my mom that I can move back
in with her for a small rain each month
and I have a friend in Iowa City who um
would let me move in for four are you
asking for permission to sell this house
I want to know I'm feeling like you
don't want to John feels like you do
what do you want to do
in a perfect world
um I would do not want to sell this
house that's what I feel the way you
said hold on a second the way you set up
those two scenarios I could just hear it
on you you don't want to move back with
your parents and you don't want to sell
the house for 15 more than you paid for
uh to your friend because you want to
kind of have your own house and so if if
I don't want to do something before I
decide on these options that I don't
want I want to figure out how is it that
I can do what I want and and I'm going
to tell you this is an income issue
you're doing it uh work is that it
support help desk type work
bro you're 21. uh and you've got some
basic I.T skills if not more than Basics
I think there's two things that I would
I would think of number one how do I
grow in my I.T career if I want to go
into I.T if I want to go into it and
stay in I.T dude you're talking about
hustling a couple of side hustles or one
good side hustle some freelance I.T work
and you're making enough money to do two
things number one uh more than have have
more than four hundred dollars left okay
number two
actually go you've got enough to pay for
some qualifications like for instance
Bethel Tech they're a partner of the Ken
Coleman show they got a nine month
program online and for about twelve five
you could go through that program and
you're gonna be making 75 to 100 grand
out of the gate
so how could I make more money to a
have more margin and B pay for some
qualifications to move up that would be
the first two questions I'd be digging
into before I asked for permission to
sell my house to a friend or move back
with Mom and here's some simple math Man
if you get a new job or a raise for 8
400 that would increase you 8 400 so you
said you make 40 Grand a year correct if
you made forty eight five
you a little bit more cover what your
roommate's been paying you
yeah yeah
and I don't know an I.T guy on planet
Earth that makes less than fifty
thousand yeah they don't work here
right this is my first this is my first
career job yes and the people who hired
you are taking full advantage of that
fact
yes and they may be maybe not in in Iowa
City I'm not but the point is John's
making the right Point here is that dude
the freelance economy right now is
massive
just go type in Google freelance economy
or freelance job market and watch the
Articles one after another going it's
hotter than it's ever been there are a
lot of small businesses in Iowa City
John that can't afford you full-time Bo
but they could afford a month
and so John's right I mean I
here's the point you don't want to sell
the house and you don't want to move
back in with Mom and Dad
and you don't have to
you've created a narrative that those
are your only two options or your best
two options and I don't know I'm not
sure I agree with that and let me if you
can learn this lesson I'm about to tell
you at 21 you win
and I didn't learn it until I was 40.
whenever I see an option like a set of
directions in my life and I narrow them
down to either or I'm almost always
wrong
so when you feel like there's only this
option or that option you're probably
not seeing the full field yep there's
always a third and a fourth and a fifth
option they may be ludicrous but there's
always another shot
by the way uh I don't wanna I don't want
to brag but my fourth and fifth options
are better than your your
excuse me my three my three and four are
better than your first two and as a
matter of fact I want you to just give
the folks a Bethel Tech a call okay
betheltech.net Ken Coleman call them
talk to them kick the tires check out
three or four other trade schools that
are in Tech
and and by the way and then start
looking for freelance work go look at
all the help wanted ads freelance
part-time Tech work and and I think
you're gonna love life bro you're going
to have a empty house with no roommates
more money making snow angels in the
carpet dude it's gonna be awesome yes
absolutely Bogue do you believe you can
do this
permission is not ours to give John
but I'm not giving him permission to
sell this house or go live with Mom what
say you yeah I mean you're right I I got
from your voice you you wanted to sell
this thing and you had people pressuring
you not to I was I was way off man I
I think you've got 50 options
well yeah here's what's happening your
brain is telling you to sell the house
to just relieve the stress but your
heart is not telling you to sell the
house my mind keeps telling me no yeah
and hey here's the other thing you had a
picture in your head that you two guys
are going to be roommates and Bros
forever
like dude let's get a house that'll be
awesome I'll buy it and we'll grow down
and then he moved out and now it's like
sad bro and it's all good this is the
picture change yeah it's fine it's cool
man yeah you got this man listen you're
21 with an unbelievable future ahead of
you and that's the mindset you gotta
have this is a hiccup I get it totally
normal to feel stressed out about this
change uh but we've got to get on the
other side of that and go what are the
best options I think you'll be full of
regret if you sell I think you're full
of regret if you live with Mom uh and
and you don't need to do any of this get
busy man take all of that pressure and
all that stress and just put it into
getting busy and making some more money
I think you're gonna be surprised at how
much of a lid you put on yourself
fascinating stuff John yeah
man
oh man I can't tell you how many times I
backed myself into a corner and I create
chaos where that doesn't need to be it's
almost never either or